Mayotte novembre 2022
sur la route de l'école un bus est
attaqué par des jeunes cagoulés
armés de Machete il force l'entrée du
bus avant d'y pénétrer
[Musique]
un assaut d'une rare violence pour voler
quelques téléphones bilan de l'attaque 5
jeunes blessés par des coups de machette
et des éclats de vitres
à Mayotte la violence n'est pas nouvelle
sur le territoire la délinquance explose
et l'immigration et galopante en
provenance des îles voisines des Comores
à tel point que dans ce département
français les maorets sont aujourd'hui
moins nombreux que les étrangers
pourtant les expulsions sont massives et
représentent chaque année près de 10% de
la population officielle
des actions qui n'apaissent pas la
colère des habitants de plus en plus
remonté contre cette spirale sans fin
c'est pour le
[Musique]
quelques semaines après l'attaque du bus
l'heure est au bilan pour la société
Matisse qui gère la moitié du transport
scolaire de Lille
alors ça c'est notre bûche du 16
novembre dernier qui s'est fait
totalement pulvériser par une attaque de
nigelle des vitres cassées à coups de
pierre à coups de couteau qu'on appelle
le chombo ici donc aucune vitre on a
tenu j'ai perdu 80% du vitrage de ce
véhicule
donc là on a des coups de couteau qui
pénètrent la tôle donc autant vous dire
que si c'est de la chair c'est un bras
qui tombe il reste encore des stigmates
ici donc de quelqu'un qui qui était
assis là et qui s'est pris un coup de
couteau à travers la vitre
donc voilà c'est le véhicule à l'origine
du dernier droit de retraite c'est
appliqué sur l'île mais c'est
malheureusement que l'un de ceux qui se
font agresser chaque jour chaque semaine
et chaque mois qui s'écoule depuis
depuis plus de 2 ans
venez je vais vous montrer d'autres
éléments
donc ça c'est le dernier arrivage de
pare-brise pour nos véhicules c'est l'un
des seuls éléments que je peux pas
remplacer avec du plexiglas c'est un
organe de protection essentiel donc là
j'en ai pour 70 000 euros et j'en ai
encore une commande de 20 000 qui arrive
dans 10 jours j'ai plus de place pour
les stocker mais malheureusement Mayotte
ils vont s'écouler très vite
donc voilà je vais vous montrer les
zones que nous nous desservons donc le
groupement naren dreambelly dessert
toute la zone nord de l'île et toute la
zone sud et nous traversons obligatoires
le point chaud qui se situe entre
zoomonier
et Kawi et c'est sur cet axe là que se
concentre 70% de nos incidents
chaque jour au moins un bus est
confronté à un incident mettant en péril
l'activité de transport scolaire les
droits de retrait nous ont coûté à
l'échelle du groupement près d'un demi
million d'euros c'est à dire que nous
sommes rémunérés au kilomètre quand nous
ne roulons pas parce que nos conducteurs
ont peur de prendre le service nous ne
sommes pas rémunérés en face de ça on
rajoute 200 000 pour réparer nos buffets
acier donc on est déjà 700 000 euros de
dépenses qui n'est pas prévu pour un
groupe de transporteurs ça devient
intenable la délinquance pourrit la
viande Mayotte certaines personnes qui
se sentent un sentiment d'impunité en
disant je me fais attraper je me fais
relâcher je recommence demain ils sont
en train de nous tuer ils sont en train
de tuer toute une génération qui veut
juste aller à l'école comme n'importe
quel français
[Musique]
à l'origine de ces attaques de plus en
plus fréquentes des jeunes mineurs
isolés étrangers ils sont plusieurs
milliers réfugiés dans les bidons villes
de Lille à vivre de la délinquance
majoritairement arrivé des Comores
voisines de façon clandestine il tente
la périlleuse traversée d'à peine 60 km
qui sépare l'île d'Anjouan aux Comores
des côtes mahoraises dans l'espoir d'un
avenir meilleur
chaque jour ou presque des bateaux de
pêche surchargés de migrants débarquent
sur les plages de l'ouest et du Sud
impuissant les élus locaux sont dépassés
par la situation
on descend
en fait les bateaux arrivent du nord de
l'entraîneur
mais puisque là-bas il fut un temps il y
avait énormément de contrôle tout le
monde savait que qu'ils arrivaient là
les ils ont décidé de descendre un peu
au sud et donc il descendent ici et très
régulièrement là j'arrive à 50 mètres
vraiment ils sont dans dans les cailloux
là et puis il viennent ici et il remonte
ici pour s'abriter dans les hauteurs
bataille pour obtenir de nouveaux moyens
pour lutter contre cette immigration au
plus près des zones d'arrivée car si des
bateaux de la police aux frontières sont
en permanence en mer leur base de départ
est située à l'opposé de l'île une
aberration pour les élus
le point de chute si je puis dire à
partir d'un juin c'est ici un symbolo
c'est ici
comme nous le demandons depuis des
années effectivement il faut il faut il
faut que l'emplacement soit stratégique
c'est 20 dernières années l'immigration
a fait exploser la démographie de Lille
la population a doublé de 150 000 à 300
000 habitants sans compter tous les
migrants illégaux il y a plus de 50% de
la population à Mayotte qui est en
situation irrégulière
partout au monde on connaît pas ça
on disait tout à l'heure il y a des
études qui disent comme Mayotte il y a à
peu près 700 000 habitants
officiellement on est à 300000 là
récemment lycée la collection que lycée
a fait 300000 c'est pas vivable pendant
des années on a parlé d'une bombe à
retardement et bien là la bombe a pété
en fait la bombe a pété et la
déflagration et là il faut faire en
sorte que c'est déflagration soit la
moins pire possible une bombe migratoire
et démographique contre laquelle les
élus tendent de lutter avec leurs moyens
en détruisant notamment les habitations
en tôle qu'on appelle banga sur le
quartier là il y avait à peu près une
centaine de familles
et
et il y avait
des bidonvilles des bangers
en tôle comme ça
donc ils étaient là tout là c'était il y
avait des banques partout là jusqu'à là
j'essaie d'envoyer régulièrement la
police municipale je travaille également
avec la population pour qu'il m'a l'air
il y a eu deux tentatives trois
tentatives ici de réinstallation et tout
de suite j'ai utilisé le la procédure
d'urgence là et on est venu casser ce
qu'il est en train de construire ceux
qui sont expulsés d'ici tout le monde
n'est pas forcément reconduit même les
irréguliers ils peuvent être accueillis
à la commune d'après ou à la suivante
et ça ça escamote le travail
[Musique]
face à cette immigration l'état mène une
politique massive d'expulsion des
clandestins lorsqu'ils sont arrêtés en
mer ou sur le territoire les migrants
sont conduits ici au centre de rétention
de Mayotte le CRA
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur
bonjour bonjour
je suis le commandant Dominique bessinat
je suis le chef du centre de rétention
bienvenue chez nous
c'est le centre de rétention qui a de
loin la plus forte activité de France
on va faire le chemin d'intégration d'un
étranger en situation régulière qui
arrive au centre de rétention
on a une moyenne à peu près de 82 si on
lit sur l'année à peu près 82 personnes
intégrées chaque jour au centre de
rétention le centre de rétention
accueille en moyenne plus de 30 000
aussi par an sur la moyenne de
l'ensemble des cas de France globalement
sur l'année 2021 on a accueilli nous
avons accueilli 63% de l'ensemble des
rétentions en France
l'immense majorité sera renvoyée aux
Comores
en 2021 20 000 migrants ont été expulsés
de Mayotte sur un total de 26 000
reconduites à la frontière pour
l'ensemble du territoire français
assisté en fait à une intégration d'un
étrangère qui est interpellé ce matin
par la PAF alors qu'il se trouve en
situation angulaire donc là il a fait le
les premières mesures de sécurité
fouille des bagages
détection d'éventuelles objets dangereux
et là donc le collègue vient de le
notifier en fait tous les droits
préférants à sa mesure de rétention on
est ici avant tout pour permettre aux
personnes qui est retenu dans le cadre
de sa présence irrégulière sur le
territoire appliquer ses droits et
respecter cette personne on le fait avec
l'humanité mais avec rigueur puisque le
volume qui vous a été dit par recommandé
30000 personnes qui sont ici retenus par
an nous oblige à avoir cette cette
procédure très rigoureuse
numéro 2
la procédure est bien rodée les clans
destins ne passent que quelques heures
dans le centre et sont expulsés en moins
de 24 heures
du coup on va faire deux rotation donc
on va amener les premiers bateaux on va
revenir et prendre la deuxième
la deuxième partie dans un second temps
en fait
une organisation faut pas que ça traîne
donc c'est toute une procédure
[Musique]
une activité intense qui justifie un
poste unique en France de Sous Préfet
dédié à la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine 25 000 personnes par an 50
000 personnes tous les deux ans
100 000 personnes tous les quatre ans si
l'État ne faisait pas ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui cette situation qu'on aurait
ici à Mayotte donc oui on continue à
travailler oui on renforce notre action
oui le gouvernement a
l'attention est plus que l'intention
mais à la volonté de mettre les choses
en place pour pour aider Mayotte
[Musique]
ce matin là ce sont encore près de 80
comoriens qui sont expulsés du
territoire depuis le centre de rétention
direction le port
l'accompagnement des policiers français
s'arrête ici sur le quai
allez
[Musique]
c'est un bateau commercial sur lequel on
embarque et retenues et qui seront qui
seront renvoyés aux Comores sur un même
sur un même bateau qu'avec des passagers
en fait commerciaux on fait
d'éloignement en métropole par bateau ou
par avion mais on met jamais sans ou 150
personnes éloignées en même temps sur un
bateau quoi non il y a qu'ici qu'on
fasse qu'on voit ça tout à fait
pour le bateau est parti c'est que tout
va bien et on souffle et on attend les
intégrations suivantes en fait et ça
c'est le rythme le rythme du crâne
éloignement le matin intégration
l'après-midi et on recommence le
lendemain sur un rythme assez assez
effréné en fait quoi c'est assez
conséquent voilà
[Musique]
sur les vins à 25000 personnes expulsées
chaque année impossible de savoir
combien retenterons la traversée vers
Mayotte
mais partout sur l'île le constat est le
même les illégaux sont toujours plus
nombreux et la délinquance progresse
les forces de l'ordre sont bien
présentes multipliant contrôle et
interpellation mais aux yeux des
habitants la réponse reste insuffisante
certains ont décidé de s'organiser en
fondant des comités citoyens
ouais donc voilà c'est c'est ici qu'on
se retrouvait en fait
régulièrement au cours dans le courant
des années 2015 par là où vraiment la
situation a commencé à dégénérer bon on
a cherché un emplacement dans le village
qui pouvait se prêter à faire à se
rencontrer en fait régulièrement parce
qu'on était quand même une bonne
quinzaine une bonne vingtaine et
beaucoup de gens se faisaient attaquer
moi je me souviens ma place favorite
c'était ici parce que d'ici en fait je
pouvais un peu voir tranquillement tout
le monde et donc c'est à partir de là
que la réflexion a commencé à monter
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les élus nous ont
abandonné les la population est plus que
jamais en colère parce qu'on n'a pas
obtenu grand chose par rapport à la
sécurisation de du territoire et au
contraire on est en train de tomber
comme des mouches et ben on s'est dit
bah c'est le il faut s'engager
ça va ça va
c'est comité organise alors des
patrouilles et interviennent en cas de
problème dans le village mais face à des
délinquants déterminés ils le font
parfois opérer de leur vie on nous
appelle comme quoi les voisins étaient
cambriolés et il y a eu des ordinateurs
qui ont été volés des portables des
tablettes et donc on est parti les
chercher on a trouvé certains éléments
sur la par terre et donc ça nous
encourageait à suivre à chercher et à un
moment donné on est arrivé ici
même c'est juste en bas là
on est tombé vraiment c'était là né
année avec deux individus qu'on le
connaissait forcément pas jamais vu les
visages et donc moi je me retrouve à un
moment là avec lui j'essaie de le
rattraper de le rattraper comme ça et en
fait il avait une machette que j'avais
pas vu et il me l'a assainé ici même
sans sommation ni quoi que ce soit
à l'époque c'était le c'était
c'était le début en fait de cette
violence à outrance et moi j'imaginais
pas jusque là jusque on pouvait comme ça
consciemment donner un coup de machette
sur quelqu'un
des histoires comme celle-là il y en a
des centaines à Mayotte
[Musique]
des fées qui plongent la population dans
la colère en 2018 les collectifs se sont
réunis ont manifestés pour dénoncer
l'abandon de l'État pendant plus de deux
mois ils ont bloqué les routes et la vie
du territoire obtenant une fine et un
engagement financier pour des
infrastructures et davantage de force de
sécurité
pour le représentant de l'État sur place
oui les attentes sont immenses mais
l'engagement est là la population veut
des choses concrètes il faut que
l'arrivée des forces le travail que nous
menons sur le terrain permettent de
montrer que les choses changent détruire
aussi l'habitat illégal qui est
aujourd'hui un lieu pour les immigrés
clandestins mais aussi un lieu pour les
délinquants en 2021 on a démoli 1615
dans ce qu'on appelle des opérations de
démolition de bidonville de la loi elon
j'ai aussi des remontées qui nous disent
Monsieur le Préfet on sait les efforts
qui sont faits par l'État on voit la
présence des forces il y a plus de monde
il y a plus de gendarmes il y a plus de
policiers c'est dur mais on sent que ça
change
la destruction des habitations illégales
et notamment devenu une priorité des
autorités les mères se sont emparés du
dossier mais cela les expose à des
représailles c'est élu témoigne il a été
menacé après la destruction de
bidonville mais ça s'est passé ici et
derrière vous c'était 14 octobre en
début de soirée ou m'appeler pour me
dire que la voiture de ma femme est
incendié et quand j'arrive sur place je
me suis rendu compte que il y avait
seulement non seulement la sienne et les
miennes aussi qui étaient complètement
calciné le soir même on a dû
j'ai envie de dire prendre la chute tout
simplement avec ma famille parce que
vous savez pas ce qui allait se passer
après j'avais peur que qu'ils viennent
s'attaquer carrément à la maison des
bâtiments publics sont régulièrement
pris pour cibles par les délinquants
tout symbole de l'État peut être attaqué
j'étais pas le seul malheureusement il y
a mon collègue qui que vous voyez à côté
de moi aussi dont la voiture a été
samedi le lendemain parce que il se
trouve que
[Musique]
sur l'île malgré les destructions quatre
habitations sur 10 se situent dans des
bidons villes
à wangani ce quartier existe depuis 25
ans c'est les quartiers compagnie
à l'intérieur desquels sont concentré
pas mal de problèmes au-delà des
problèmes de salubrité où vous verrez
quand il pleut ici
c'est très compliqué pour les habitants
qui les circuler
[Musique]
exactement donc plusieurs projets sont
prévus d'ailleurs si on arrive le jour
où les habitants eux-mêmes comprendront
que c'est pour leur bien qu'il faudrait
démolir et puis reconstruire je pense
qu'on aura réglé une grosse partie du
problème pour les réguliers tout
simplement on démolit et on reconstruit
avec tous les services qu'il faut
une solution pour ceux qui ont des
papiers mais qui laissent entier le
problème des îles légaux toujours plus
nombreux
car l'immigration comorienne provoque un
raz-de-marais démographique à Mayotte la
seule maternité de Lille et la plus
grande d'Europe avec chaque année plus
de 10 000 naissances les trois quarts de
ces bébés ont des parents étrangers
depuis 2019 ils n'ont plus accès
automatiquement à la nationalité
française ici le droit du Soleil a été
modifié cet animaux à mettre soit Lille
qui a porté le changement au Sénat c'est
que aujourd'hui
les clandestins se disent on y va on va
tenter notre chance peuvent rester un
mois 10 ans
il donne naissance à un enfant
et lorsqu'il y a des reconduites à la
frontière
il montre la pièce l'acte de naissance
ils disent je suis une excuse une
expulsable parce que j'ai donné
naissance à un enfant sur le sol
français et c'est cette logique qu'il
faut casser
et conditionner d'abord la situation
régulière de l'un des parents et ça va
changer énormément de choses pour
l'adoption 248 contre 94 le Sénat a
adopté
[Applaudissements]
une mesure qui n'a pas endigué le rythme
des naissances une partie des élus veut
aller encore plus loin
ici on est devant le service immigration
de la préfecture c'est noir de monde des
deux côtés de la rue à tel point que les
voitures ne n'arrivent même pas à passer
et c'est comme ça tous les jours tous
les jours et devant les yeux des
Mahorais c'est quelque chose qui
exaspere qui énerve
ces dispositions sont certes
dérogatoires et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
veiller à leur constitutionnalité mais
elles sont nécessaires sinon comment
avec des dispositions de droit commun
voulez-vous répondre à la situation
migratoire qui se pose à Mayotte il faut
faire passer le message que le projet
qui consiste à venir à Mayotte donner
naissance à un enfant dans la
perspective qu'il est dans la
nationalité française cette idée il faut
l'abandonner parce que ça ne marchera
plus
malgré toutes ces mesures ce bout de
France continue d'attirer les migrants
en quête de vie meilleure
au grand désespoir de la population qui
cède à la résignation nombre sont les
mahorés et les natifs de métropole a
quitté le territoire
Gilles Renaud est une figure de l'île
ici tout le monde le connaît à 70 ans
dont plus de 30 ans passés à Mayotte ce
peintre ouvre chaque jour sa galerie
[Musique]
la voilà ma galerie ma galerie de
peinture ça fait 22 ans qu'elle est
ouverte à ce jour elle reste la seule à
Mayotte
tableau et aquarelle sont ici aux
couleurs vives joyeuses tout autant que
les scènes représentées symboles d'un
maillot d'Anton je pense que je trouve
beau je le peinte pour mon plaisir et je
le peins en fonction de mes sentiments
c'est sûr que je prenne pas Mamoudzou
non là j'en peux plus c'est une des
raisons qui font que je vais quitter
Mayotte il y a trop de monde il y a les
phénomènes de violence qui s'accentuent
depuis deux ou trois ans
un manque de contrôle parce que on les
contrôle plus aujourd'hui on est on a
passé le point de non-retour ils sont
totalement incontrôlables
Gilles qui a mené 1000 vies a décidé de
s'installer sur l'île de Madagascar à
400 km d'ici c'est peut-être la galerie
ce qui me fait le plus de peine en
quittant Mayotte j'ai de regrets pour
rien
ma galerie manquera ma foi on en fera
une autre après
[Musique]
ces dernières toiles mahores iront
garnir les magasins de Mayotte et seront
achetés par les clients friands de ces
images bien éloignées de la situation
actuelle de Lille un parfum du passé une
nostalgie je plains Mayotte je lui
souhaite bonne chance pour son futur je
suis pas très optimiste pour elle c'est
un endroit que j'ai aimé profondément
que j'aime toujours mais bon l'évolution
actuelle de l'île me fait chercher des
cieux plus clément plus calme plus
paisible pour continuer de peindre tout
le temps
[Musique]